What Happened to Howard Hughes' Money After
He Died
Over his lifetime, Howard Hughes’ wallet
became one of the fattest of his time.
It isn’t known exactly how much he was worth
at the time of his death, but ten years before
he died, he was forced to sell his shares
in the airline company TWA.
The payout?
$546 million (about $3.8 billion today), estimated
by some to have been about 1/3 of his net
worth.
When he died, there was one major problem:
Hughes had no direct descendants or immediate
family, and he didn’t leave behind a will.
At least, that’s what authorities were forced
to conclude after an extensive search for
one.
After contacting his various banks, lawyers,
and employees, every hotel he’d ever stayed
in, posting classifieds in various newspapers,
and even consulting a psychic, they were forced
to accept that settling the massive estate
was not going to be an easy matter.
So just where did all of that money go after
his death?
Most assumed he wanted the money to go to
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
It was well-known that he didn’t want the
money falling into the hands of any distant
relatives, but without hard evidence, distant
cousins and others began snatching for the
cash.
A battle ensued between the temporary administrator
of the Hughes estate, cousin and lawyer William
Lummis, and those who ran the Medical Institute.
It was a multi-state war, with Nevada, California,
and Texas all claiming to be responsible for
the distribution of the state, and all of
which had their own laws about inheritance.
While the various parties were fighting it
out, a couple of different wills surfaced,
though eventually thrown out as fakes.
A notable one was the three-page document
that declared Melvin Dummar, a gas station
attendant, was to inherit 1/16 of Hughes’
fortune.
Supposedly, Dummar once picked Hughes up off
the side of the road and gave him a ride to
his hotel, and Hughes was so grateful that
he left Dummar a huge chunk of money.
In 1978, the will was thrown out as a forgery.
Next, “wives” started emerging from Hughes’
past, taking advantage of his reclusive reputation
to explain why no one had heard of them before.
Terry Moore, an actress, claimed to have married
Hughes twice, but provided no documentation
to support her assertions.
She did, in fact, once live with Hughes in
the 1940s, but her claim that they were not
only married, but never divorced, was called
into question given the fact that she married
three times after her supposed marriage to
Hughes.
Nevertheless, she must have put forward a
good argument, or at least pestered the estate
managers so much that they decided to pay
her just to get rid of her, because she was
paid $400,000 by the estate.
Later, Moore wrote a book titled Beauty and
a Billionaire which made the bestseller list,
likely lining her pockets a bit more.
In addition to supposed wives, an extraordinary
number of Hughes’ supposed children decided
to acknowledge their deceased father.
One was said to be the lovechild of Hughes
and Amelia Earhart, even though Earhart never
had any children.
At least two were black, but their claims
were thrown out as Hughes was known to be
quite the racist.
After years of struggle trying to sort the
people with legitimate claims from the fakers
who were in it to try to grab some of the
cash, a lot of the money did end up going
to the Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
However, a huge chunk of it also went to various
Hughes heirs.
According to the Wall Street Journal, around
1000 people have benefited from the estate,
including 200 of Hughes’ distant relatives.
After liquefying many of his assets, they
collectively were awarded over a billion dollars.
Interestingly, the liquidation of the estate
wasn’t completely finalized until 2010—34
years after his death.
The last piece of the puzzle was the Summerlin
residential development.
In 1996, Rouse Co. (now General Growth) agreed
to buy the Summerlin land from the Hughes’
estate on a 14-year repayment plan.
With that, finally, the estate of Howard Hughes
was laid to rest.
Bonus Howard Hughes Facts:
• Howard Hughes was born on Christmas Eve
in 1905 into a family who ran a very successful
oil tool business.
He inherited that business when he turned
eighteen—his parents had died the year before—and
just like that, he was a millionaire.
With his new wealth he decided to fund a few
films rather than manage the family business.
His most popular movie was Hell’s Angels,
the World War I flying epic, which fueled
Hughes’ interest in aviation.
It cost around $4 million to make (about $54
million today) and also grossing about $8
million.
It helped catapult Howard Hughes into Hollywood
fame.
His name was even coupled with the likes of
Ginger Rogers, Ava Gardner, and Katherine
Hepburn.
• Hughes’ true love was flying.
He suffered from partial deafness and complained
of a constant ringing in his ears, but when
he was in the air, the ringing stopped, or
at least was drowned out by other noises.
Credited with many successful aviation inventions,
he was also well-known for the Spruce Goose,
a wooden sea plane that Hughes worked on tirelessly
until its completion in 1947.
The plane was only flown once, partially because
Hughes began withdrawing from aviation and
from society after being involved in a horrific
plane crash in 1946.
• Hughes lived a fascinating life, but the
end of his life was nearly as interesting,
if a bit peculiar.
He gained a reputation as a recluse, conducting
nearly all of his business from a suite in
the Desert Hotel, which he owned.
According to the few handlers who managed
things for him, the fabulous Hollywood playboy
started letting himself go in the last twenty-five
years of his life.
His hair was constantly dirty and his teeth
were rotten, he became addicted to drugs,
and he had an obsession with germs.
When he died on April 5, 1976, he weighed
just 92 pounds.